ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show the super bowl was uh won by
the la rams
and uh what uh what who cares but a lot
of people do and um the people that
uh
don't pretend to and that's lovely and
la's obviously a lot of actors and
people are really you know they're like
yeah but a week ago they didn't know who
the rams were and they didn't care but
it's just fun it's fun it's like drugs
there's a reason for it there's a reason
to be [ __ ] up
um and then there's a lot of other
people that really care but you know
there's a lot of people that i think are
pretending they seem to be
you know they seem to be a little bit
more moved than they're actually
than they truly are because tomorrow
they wake up they don't care it's back
to them
it's a nice collective experience for a
city that doesn't really like the
collective it's more of an independent
city about you
and what you're up to
but
someone's done something else it does
directly involve you
and it's nice to pretend to care about
it even though you most people don't
the people that do are like regular
people that are not in la to like make
you know make like something or make it
they're human beings who live in l.a and
work and have families they care but the
people that i'm around and the people
that i you know observe
are pretending to care
because it allows them to have a
collective experience
even though it's fraudulent
and not real it allows them
for a few minutes to pretend that they
can enjoy
something outside of themself
which is completely they're incapable of
doing
and this allows them to pretend that
they can do that which they cannot but
you know
it's fun
it's fun we just got hassled by the lapd
on the way to the studio two cops pulled
us over an asian guy and a bold guy
and uh we had inched over the line what
was it the line of the the traffic line
the uh intersection line now by the way
he
he was next to us the cops and we pulled
up to where he was and then he pulled up
so i kind of thought i could pull up
because i figured that well he's pulling
up i guess i could pull up but
you know what he's basically saying is
we're pulling up because
for our own safety we don't like people
next to us because we think you could
take shots at us or whatever which again
you know and we weren't planning to do
but i didn't realize that that i know
it's bad out there but i didn't realize
i didn't think he was like oh
they're gonna shoot us in the head
so we'll go up
so he moved up i moved up and then he
looked it up he looked at me
and do you remember the first thing he
said i don't really remember is it sir
why did you roll through the line there
have you been drinking tonight yeah you
guys are drinking tonight i'm like the
first of all the light is green i'm like
right it's a green light so i'm i'm
going through the green light
okay
that's uh how it works
and he's like well i'm going to pull you
over to do a dewey check and i'm like
i had exhibited no behavior of drinking
i was not swerving
uh there was no smell of marijuana or
alcohol in the car
um
you know there was nothing going on
we're on our way to the studio
every time i defend the cops by the way
and when i say i defend the cops i just
defend the idea that there needs to be a
police force i don't really defend the
cops per se
i just defend the idea that you need to
have
some enforcement of the law or rich
people just hire mercenaries
um
and then chaos ensues
but every time i even try to defend that
you know you you you have interactions
with these people and they're always bad
and they're always like kind of abusive
and i'm a white guy in a nice car
imagine if i was a black guy what they
could get away with doing they bait you
into saying something disrespectful so
that they can bring you in he kept
threatening me with other first of all
we pull over okay
and you can tell he's mentally unstable
many of the people in the lapd are
mentally unstable okay this is not their
first choice of employment
he identified himself as a dre hey what
was it again a drug recognition a drug
recognition
expert he's an expert on recognizing
when people are on drugs
because apparently that's hard
to do
it's an art it's a science
because you would never know when
someone's on drugs unless you had a drug
recognition
expert
so lucky
so now this drug recognition expert
based on the fact that i was not
swerving not slurring
no smell of alcohol or marijuana
but i was answering his questions
coherently he was like oh he must be
[ __ ] up
so he he pulls me over and then he
starts going at me
he goes if you had a drink i said not in
13 years which is true
and he goes okay
and then i'm like
he goes well we're gonna do a test here
uh and he pulls out a pen
and he goes what color is the pen no
it's a clear pen
it's a clear pen that looks bluish
purplish kind of
it's a weird tint it's a bic pen
i got i don't know blue clear he's like
oh he thinks he's got someone
like dummy first of all it's not even a
sobriety test the sobriety test you get
me out of the car
this is like a waste of both of our time
you just want to bait me into saying
something crazy you could bring me in
and then you don't have to do your job
for the rest of the night i get it
so this emotionally unstable lunatic
uh then has me follow the pen cap with
my eyes he's like don't move your head
just your eyes which i can do i go to
the left you know right left right we
got it
i complete that
and he goes um
you know he's kind of a dick he's being
a dick
and
i go to rental
here's the insurance
i've not had a drink in 12 years we're
going to work
he's being a dick so then he's more of a
dick starts lecturing me about dewy's
and
you know whatever and this is my job and
i'm like okay but i passed we're done
so then as he's leaving i go scumbag to
ben because i was yelling at ben
but here's the deal with them you can't
say to their face they'll put you in
jail but what you do is you say to
someone in the car something about them
because that's freedom of speech but if
you say to them they will say that you
are being
uh
whatever menacing threatening or that
you are uh out you know because he's
like he alluded to the fact that he
could take me in for multiple tests uh
he goes here's that's only one test
there's many tests so what he's
basically saying is say the wrong thing
i'll bring you in you'll pee in a cup
we'll do blood whatever it is you know
which then i call a million lawyers and
we go to war with piggy blue collar
piggy pig
but
we don't want to do that you know what i
mean we don't want to do that okay
but
uh he's uh you know drunk on his own
power
uh a uh not the brightest bulb
[Music]
um you know he's on on dewey enforcement
in beverly hills right
um
and then he comes back he goes what was
that i was like oh i didn't see anything
i said i have freedom of speech it's my
own car i can say whatever i want
because well what did you say i said
it's none of your concern and then we
just start fighting like going at it for
what about 20 minutes 20 minutes 20
minutes going back and forth with this
civil servant slob
about um you know why i have rights
that's all
about why i have rights and why this
idiot
uh doesn't get to just you know
uh and again this is the pandemic or
whatever it is it's going back to 911
it's like
this is instilled and i'm like i'm like
with the city falling apart with people
getting killed smashing grabs robberies
do you think the best use of your time
right now is to argue with a guy that
we've proven is sober and is not
breaking any laws
do you think that's the best use of your
time he's like well what do you do for a
living i said i'm gavin newsom's
personal assistant
that's exactly what i said
i said that's what i do
and we got back and forth i said i'm
somewhat well known i said i'm not crazy
well-known compared to other people but
i'm decently well-known because he goes
he said some [ __ ] about you have you
ever been shot at i'm like no i defend
cops
on large platforms i've said nice things
about cop i'm gonna take them all back
he's like have you ever met someone
who's been the victim of a dewey no
aren't they dead
isn't that your point
he's like do you know have you ever gone
to a dewey scene
no
is that something i'm even allowed to do
am i even allowed to just go to dewey
scenes
to look at mangled people
to learn
i'm not drinking
but again the cops are abusive and
belligerent and they're trying to make
you say something they're trying to trip
you up it's incredibly unprofessional
that the way that they behave and act
and it's
sad but i was um i you know argued my
position pretty well i said hey buddy
like
you know at any time did you think i was
gonna go in
yeah i thought i thought we weren't
getting the episode in in time for sure
well no but did you think i was going to
jail no i didn't think you were going to
jail but i thought it might escalate a
little bit more but i did a good job i
held your ground i hope i got because
what the the thing is is they're so used
to just
trampling on people's civil liberties
and rights
um
like for example
i'm not drunk we've proven i'm not drunk
i made a comment to my friend in the car
guess what it's none of your business
that i said you were a scumbag
if i say to your face i like people who
say things to my face i'm like because
you can bring him to jail that's what
you like liar
you're a liar
you you're you're a power crazed
psychopath
you're the entire reason
we have [ __ ] problems right now in
this country because you people show up
somewhere and start firing wildly
because you're all insane
okay not all of you but far too many
let's be clear
far too many of you are [ __ ] out
there causing real problems he's an
asian guy he's like they said i was
racist
and they were spitting on me and i
didn't take them to jail i'm like number
one you probably did number two
i'm not spitting on you i'm telling you
uh that i have a right
as a human being i'm sorry that uh
doesn't sit well with you
but when i said gavin newsom's personal
assistant the bald guy laughed yeah the
other cop on the other side yeah the
ball baldy laughed but yeah i mean you
know what are you gonna do this is why
the lapd i mean they're the most corrupt
police force in the country so they
don't do much but whatever they do is
always bad like whatever they get
involved with is uh horrendous
so you're glad that they but what's
going on with the ukraine everyone's uh
going on about this ukraine now you
can't leave the house without people in
the grocery store going ukraine
what's gonna happen do you think because
here's what's happening for the
uninitiated for the the people that
don't know um
vladimir putin
who is that and this is
i
i was stunned when i read the full story
about this
there is a
couple
who wants to be in the olympics
and they are
non-binary
and they are from
russia
and vladimir putin is not letting them
into the olympics because he you know he
does not like gay people
this is this is the whole thing
we are going to have to have a nuclear
war
with russia
have you heard this we're going to have
to have because i thought this was like
the ukraine joining nato and like like
nato pushing further into russia's
territory and then kind of like you know
they're kind of prone to invasion and
them kind of freaking out going hey
you're encircling us like would you like
it if if we encircled you like that like
don't you see but it's not about them
there is a non-binary
figure skating team that is being denied
entry to the olympics by russia so we're
going to have to have a nuclear
exchange
because russia is not
as
pro
uh
progressive
as we would like
and that saddens me and it saddens many
people i know so if we have to have a
nuclear war
so be it
you know no of course that's a joke
although they are glenn greenwald made a
decent point like wokeness is now used
as kind of like the pretense for war
it's hilarious
they're like he did they're
backwards and they don't like gays so
we're gonna go in there with some nukes
like well that doesn't help that doesn't
help the gays does it
if i was getting russia i wouldn't want
um uh to be uh bombed as the way to help
that wouldn't help me probably
situation in ukraine building now to
some kind of crescendo opportunity for
mr putin says pentagon now russia's
going we're not invading but they said
that about crimea and they did go into
crimea they've got a lot of troops on
the border russia does not like being in
circle they don't like nato pushing past
germany more into russia's world and
then if the ukraine joins nato i mean
it's right on their doorstep right uh
nato of course being this uh group of
countries uh that uh the north atlantic
trade organization right yes yes and
what they basically do is you know it's
a trade organization an economic uh
political military alliance that you can
join and if the ukraine is in it it's
it's really bringing nato right to
russia's doorstep putin not
happy about this so nobody really knows
what's gonna go down
um
the ukrainian president keeps saying
that nothing's gonna happen like no
there's nothing to worry about
well the ukrainian president keeps
saying relax it's gonna be fine right
but 160 florida national guard soldiers
have safely left the ukraine
so that is
a few women in ukraine not being
sexually assaulted by
the florida national guard
we do we go to these countries we
sexually assault people i mean it's
horrible but this is what we do and then
we pretend we don't know how it
like so many complaints are like i'm
like
american cheat you know
hey you drink get in there you drink you
drunk
now
why'd you go over the line
well cause i'll you were over the line
and the light was green so we were
leaving yeah
maybe i should go over to [ __ ] korea
and assault some women
what
[Music]
i don't know what's really gonna happen
here with this and i i can't care
i don't want uh the ukraine to be
attacked
i don't want
uh
you know i don't want this
but then you know but then sometimes i
wake up and i go maybe i do
that's the problem
because sometimes i'll wake up and i go
maybe i do maybe i do want
the ukraine to get attacked
i don't know
have you ever like tried to pick
like a
flavor maybe of ice cream or something
and you're like
i just don't know that's kind of how i
feel about the ukraine i go i
i kind of don't want them to be attacked
but then i also do
what the [ __ ] is going on you stupid
[ __ ]
look at me have do you know what bird
dogs are
wake up
bird dogs are what are they even shorts
shorts bird dogs are shorts that people
wear and aren't they comfortable very
yeah why why a pair of shorts shut up
they're so comfortable they make a [ __ ]
feel nice
it feels like you're masturbating all
day doesn't it
it feels like you're getting
fondled you're getting a happy ending
massage all
[ __ ] day
you go to birddogs.com enter promo code
tim dillon they'll throw in a free bird
dog's whistle football so you can go to
the park and throw a whistle football
around
i'll tell you this you get bird dogs you
don't even need to get laid anymore
you're [ __ ] yourself all day because
these pants are comfy
comfy
c-u-m-f-y
you might say having a thousand orgasms
a day seems grotesque you ever read
about those people who just keep having
orgasms every minute oh yeah yeah it's
horrible medical condition it's horrible
it's horrible
but it's not
with bird dogs because it's not a full
one it's a nice little tickle
what do you think about the bird dogs i
like the they sent me some wacky styles
and some conventional ones too because
you know what it's funny and it's funny
yeah oh it's
it's funny
it's funny when you're underwearing are
they underwear or not well it's shorts
with the underwear on the inside where
you don't have to wear it both it's
funny to have a goofy outfit
you know why why because it's unexpected
most people don't look at
look at how much fun
these
people are having
at this dojo
where grown men are [ __ ] each other
don't you see these pants
they're
colorful and fun
bird dogs are great
do you know a statistic i read
they are
i'm not even kidding and i know
people are gonna say i'm joking about
this
they are
because they're so comfortable on the
inside
the government is testing bird dog
shorts
on pedophiles to cure them
because
it's so comfortable
do you understand what i mean yes
isn't that good
i think so what's the deal here
go to birddogs.com
promo code tim dillon they'll throw in a
free whistle football
this is birddogs.com b-r-i-d-d-o-g-s
dot com promo code tim dillon and boom a
free bird dogs football
what do you want you support the show
you get these shorts and you get
uh football and they're it's you if you
want to show your dick to people it's
right there
you don't have to go through another
layer and it's a great idea for a guy to
just be able to pull it out
what bet what what could happen
what bad things could happen
your dick should be more accessible if
you're a man
birddogs.com promo code tim dillon i
love better help so many people right
now are struggling with their mental
health especially since we've had two
years of isolation and quarantine but
here's what you're gonna do i'm telling
you better help is a great online
service it's got licensed counselors
that are great at what they do
you can change them any time if you
don't like them you can send a message
they'll get right back to you it is so
important to keep your mental health uh
going
here with a better help whether it's
hitting the gym making time for a
haircut or even trying therapy
you are your greatest asset i've always
said that to you right you're your
greatest asset yeah that's what i've
said so invest the time and effort in
yourself
like you do for other people better help
us online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chats it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours give it a try and see why
2 million people have used better help
online therapy the podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp and tim bill and show
listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.comd
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
tim d
do it now
this podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy
bay area homeowners are uh being
asked to help to house
homeless residents
in the bay area of california in
northern california they are having
problems
with uh homelessness
and the gov the government now to their
credit is no longer pretending that
they're functional remember that story
about the children who drive the
ambulances oh yeah you brought that to
my attention they didn't have anyone to
drive the ambulances so i forget where
this was but they just started enlisting
the help of i think like high school
kids
to just drive ambulances because they
couldn't find anyone else to do it and
again it was one of those feel-good
stories where they're like take a look
at this
we are so proud of our young boys and
girls
yeah in in rural sac it's harbor new
york jackets harbor new york covenant
local volunteer ambulance service local
high schools everyone has to acquire
training
just come up and ask man me and my
friends would be just baking out the
ambulance
we'd just be getting so high in that
let's watch this little segment
when people call for an ambulance in
sackett's harbor new york and the crew
shows up at their front door near 12
almost everyone has the same reaction a
lot of people just come up and ask you
like wait how old are you right you're
the emt right when's the ambulance
coming so what do you say you just
explain to them we are the ambulance
these baby-faced first responders took
over the village's emergency medical
services not long after covet hit when
all the older ems volunteers either
couldn't or wouldn't do the job anymore
that's right that exodus part of a
national trend that's rural america 35
of ambulance services are all volunteers
pay them and many maybe that's a bad
model 69
say they're struggling that's a horrible
model huh fortunately forty percent of
people coming to get you are
doing it because they want to
who is that in new york state so weird
isn't that a weird model 30 35
of ambulance workers in rural america
are volunteers
35 of people that are coming to get you
in your moment of need are doing it
because they feel like it
i mean
is that a problem
but now we got kids doing it so in the
great spirit of this because i think
this is great i think it's good everyone
pitch in
get in there and do it right
get in there and do it
get can you imagine being a young kid
well i was a piece of [ __ ] you know we
love drugs and just being on long island
being in an ambulance being high
somebody called oh [ __ ] dude we got to
get this woman
putting the siren on
so in san jose california as the bay
area continues to struggle under the
weight of its homelessness crisis
uh officials and non-profits are asking
local residents to do more than hand out
meals or donate spare change
i like that already hey
because no one's doing that either no
one's handing out meals
so i like that they're saying you got to
do more than this and people going who's
doing that
handing out meals
they're asking them to open up their
homes nearly 30 000 people are unhoused
in the five-county bay area and there
isn't nearly enough room in the region's
existing affordable housing developments
to fill the gaps
service providers increasingly are
recruiting private landlords to take in
homeless tenants
some property owners are renting out
entire units in exchange for agreements
that the government or a non-profit will
cover the rent others are offering up a
spare bedroom fund in their homes
sometimes in exchange for a small
stipend sometimes as a purely or as a
purely charitable
act
now
how does this work
because i this is a very interesting
idea
you have a spare bedroom
and you bring in someone that may be
addicted to drugs you're emotionally
unstable
and by the way
it's america so members of your
household already
may be addicted to drugs and emotionally
unstable you may be adding another
person
because that's what a lot of teenagers
are right now right you have an
emotionally unstable drug addict in the
home and now you're bringing in a buddy
you're bringing in a buddy
it's harry and the hendersons it's like
it's bringing in a fun
you know it's down and down beverly
hills watch the movie with nick nolte
it's been [ __ ] brilliant
quote here recruiting landlords also was
a challenge for the homecoming project
which houses formerly incarcerated
people a group that's often stigmatized
using donations and non-profit pace
hosts in alameda and contra costa
counties 30 a day to house someone in a
spare bedroom for six months
each former inmate is matched with a
case manager to help them find a job and
save money for a permanent home
sex offenders aren't eligible now let's
get one thing straight
i am very much for people turning your
lives around
and not being stigmatized especially
with non-violent drug charges right
i don't think people should carry these
things for the rest of their life i
don't think it should prevent them from
working
and i do think that they need a place to
stay i do though think it is quite
hilarious
that with all the money that the
government of california takes in
the only option they have is to go to
citizens and go do you have a room
that's the only option
after the billions of
tax dollars that flow into the state
of california the only thing you can do
is say hey do you guys got any rooms
sex stein
zach stein and his wife volunteered with
say by the way remember there was a
homeless guy there was a guy in beverly
wood who worked with the homeless and
i'm not dissuading anyone from working
with the homeless by just telling you
this factual story
there was a guy in beverly wood who
worked with the homeless a homeless guy
followed him home
and stabbed him to death it was
brentwood maybe let me see
i believe it was in beverly wood but it
doesn't really matter people are
listening to this from some dungeon in
wisconsin they don't understand what
we're talking about we're talking about
beverly hills piglets
homeless man uh arrested for murder at
brentwood and camp well you were right
same difference
so
that was that i think that was a
different one but but my point is this
my point is this
you gotta have cojones
to work with people that may kill you
right
zach stein and his wife volunteered with
safe time opening up their spare bedroom
in albany to a struggling young woman
for three months in some ways it was
really weird having a stranger there
stein said
but
the experience seemed to make a big
difference in the woman's life
start this was one of the andrew cuomo's
mistresses they had they
housed stein and his wife recently had a
baby and hope to continue hosting once
they get settled as parents well that
seems insane but they were able to buy
their house because they inherited money
and they want to share that good luck
with those less fortunate well that's
the beginning of a fun movie
i mean here's the deal there's a lot of
people that are down on their luck that
need help there's also a lot of people
that have real
real problems with mental illness and
drug addiction and the idea that you
would bring them into your house uh and
put your family and children at risk
seems insane to anybody and i know this
is one of those ideas that like 10
people write about on twitter and they
make it sound like it's a great idea but
human beings recoil from this
it's like you know the reason why the
democrats have lost a narrative on truly
everything right now is because the
democrats issues that have always made
sense to people are like the meat and
potatoes like
yeah people shouldn't go bankrupt when
they get in a car accident people do
need health care people should have a
retirement right people believe in those
things but when you start getting to
this extreme
of the left where they go why don't you
why don't you hey how about you open
your house
haven't you got a room
because these are millionaires
why not put them in gavin new how big is
that how big is gavin newsom's winery
can't they all go work on gavin newsom's
winery
i'm not saying you shouldn't be
charitable when you can but there's a
lot of this that screams a horrible idea
because you are not trained to deal with
people that are experiencing psychosis
you're not trained to deal with that
and it's america so there's already
people in your house with psychosis
they say no there's nothing new here
you're adding another nut
to a bag of nuts probably
talk to anyone now someone's lost it
anybody you talk to there's someone in
the house who's gone completely insane
so you're bringing in someone else and
that could be a real big problem
i just you know
i'll bring him in my house but you got
to do what i say i'll program them to
kill
if i if i adopt a homeless person can i
program them to kill
truly
if i bring if i sign up in this program
save time
can i get i want to get a [ __ ]
person in there that we can mk ultra to
do whatever we want
nothing truly violent
just like throwing a loaf of bread in a
politician
some funny
[ __ ]
good bits good goofs
can we bring in a homeless person and
teach them how to do some goofs
well if you want to if you want to open
your home to them i i
commend you
i'm not saying it's a bad idea
it's not a great idea
what was the other article that i uh i
thought was very interesting
uh there was this one with the real
housewives well this was fun this was
from a while ago um
real housewives stars axe faces felony
charges after a standoff at newport
beach home
here's the thing man you may not like
the real housewives and you may think
that they're a garbage
uh franchise and you might have
many uh arguments for that that are
valid here's what i'm telling you pay
attention
because the economy
these people that are on these shows for
the most part not all of them a few of
them have money inherited money part of
industries whatever but the vast
majority of them are con artists they're
frauds
uh
they are grifters they uh they are
you know basically living off cheap
credit they're in these uh industries
that are unregulated they're the wild
west you know when the show first
started it was in orange county
california and it was all mortgages one
guy worked at a title he owned a title
business and the other person was uh
other woman was real estate agent
the other person did this and you know
and all of them kind of were getting in
on the big uh boat load of free money
that was there and then of course as the
economy crashed uh those people also
crashed and you watched that so it's a
good indication now uh
this guy i don't even know who he is but
ryan matthew
girardi
whatever
33 of la faces one count each of
extortion by force or threat assault
with a firearm making criminal threats
corporal injury on his spouse or
cohabitant grossly negligent discharge
of a firearm and being a felon in
possession of a firearm basically what
he he put the chick he locked her up in
the house for a while he had fired a gun
in the house during a fight a couple
months ago he was uh blackmailing her to
release her nudes to the media folks let
me tell you what this means bitcoin has
not reached the bottom
let's call a spade is paid here bitcoin
has not reached the bottom
when somebody's blackmailing the wife
for the nudes and they got the
helicopters in orange county and he's
shooting a gun in the house
kryptos there's more blood in the water
that's what i'm that that is my
prediction is what i'm telling you right
now
this is not a human interest story this
is a story about economics i'm telling
you pay attention swat teams were
requested
and east balboa boulevard between island
avenue and coronado street was closed
during the standoff standoff in orange
county
means there's more blood in the water
the coins are going down
i'm telling you when these criminals
start to feel the squeeze
margin calls people need to start
covering their ass when they start
feeling the squeeze they take the gun
out in the house
i'm telling you ignore me at your own
peril
what's coming won't be able you can't
stop what's coming what's that quote
from uh no country for old that's your
favorite quote
at some point he forced vargas whoever
that is to buy him a
bmw on the 31st he shot a gun in the
homes into the home ceiling during an
argument while vargas hid in the closet
well here's what my point is here
well my point is when these people start
to get restless
you know something is
a miss
so anthony weiner is back he's hosting a
show called left verse right with curtis
sliwa now anthony weiner is uh the
husband of huma abedin who's a hillary
clinton's um
uh
assistant
and huma abedin
yeah vice chair of hillary clinton's
2016 campaign yeah yeah yeah so she's
very tight with hill
and her husband anthony weiner had an
issue because he was sexting what a 15
year old yes yes i think it was
was it 15 let me see 16. it was so it
was underage yeah i was underage was
underage but then there was some
conspiracy about it that the girl i
don't know right here 15 year old girl
was sentenced to 21 months in federal
prison 2017.
right and he did the time right
but now he's back
so he goes weiner 57 told the new york
post that's radio show
isn't part of a larger comeback plan he
goes i am not going back in a public
life i'm doing a radio show with a
friend of mine here's the thing with
anthony weiner who's a very successful
politician incredibly successful
and he was i think pissing off a lot of
rich really rich people
he's busting up industries and stuff or
whatever i don't know what he was doing
and don't don't come at me go you don't
know the half of it i don't care about a
quarter of it
you don't have a
but what i do know is that he was i i
they they you know
he was obviously acting in a deplorable
manner but they they they did seem to he
did seem to ruffle a few feathers they
got rid of him but now he's uh back
and he's doing a radio show with curtis
sliwa the guy who uh
lost
in the mayoral race against eric adams
and i don't and it's called left verse
right i mean they'll never stop with
this huh
they don't care what happens
well what disgraces people are a part of
they just go back to the left first
right paradigm they don't care who it is
they don't care what people have been
convicted of as long as because people
are watching let's first write
who's
who's gonna win the debate
adolf hitler
and [ __ ]
jeffrey epstein on left verse right
no one care as long as it's a dumb
horse race style
meaningless political show where people
will hurl insults at each other they
don't care that he was there texting a
child it doesn't matter
it's left first right
yo did you see you listen left first
right
did you see that
did you see the point jared fogle made
on left first right
it was [ __ ] good dude
it was about taxes
yeah yeah i know he had a thing with the
kid but listen to what he said about
taxes on left first right
what did you think about the super bowl
halftime show people were very happy
it's all this music we grew up with
eminem and mary j blige dr dre 50 cent i
didn't we didn't watch it we left
we went to david dobrik's house very
briefly and um
i stood there and we were there for what
about an hour about one hour very very
and they're they're sweet people but you
know i mean i don't i don't know a ton
of people there and
uh you know the food was fine but a lot
of people had eaten it nah
we're talking to jason his friend jason
nash he's very nice guy and
and then we had to go do this episode so
we're like okay
we just kind of skid out a beautiful
home here's a nice home um
but here's my thing
here's what i'll say
and he's done much better than me he has
a lot more money than me
but let me just let me just say this
about why are you laughing i'm not
why are you nervous i'm not saying
anything bad
here's the thing
about
real estate
i just you know what it is
i i have the burden of taste
it is a horrible burden
one that many people uh do not have to
suffer with while they walk the earth
and it is hard for me to look at a lot
of these la homes
and see them as anything other than like
grotesque
even though they're very beautiful and
impressive
and and you grand and whatever
but i look at these uh homes
these large doctor's offices is what
they are
they're large doctors offices
and i just can't
get into it we don't need to show the
home we don't need to do that we're not
doing that
what a horrible producer you are
why are you getting married well he does
a lot of tours of his home i know that
but don't women i'm doing a segment
about the guy's home i'm making a point
about
the aesthetic of the west coast real
estate
that i can't fully know there's some
beautiful homes here but just the modern
style is not for me
okay that's all i'm saying
that's all i'm saying
okay we're not trying to start uh
anything here i know he's a lovely
person we did not even say hello to
he was busy
does he speak english he does right
does he have an accent
no not real i mean he's the the canadian
thing a little bit is he canadian i
thought he was from somewhere else
i think he's serbian or something
well we didn't see the halftime show
at slovakian right so this halftime show
you'd think you'd have some slovakian
food you know for to honor his heritage
but there's none of that people come to
l.a they forget who they are
but i wanted some you know what i mean
it's a slovakian some slovakian food
just tick-tockers eating
the food of slovakia
um
yeah i don't care about this either i
mean i i'm i'm you know i'm trying to
care about this but i just can't care
here's what i'll say about it i love the
music but it's like seeing like the
white chicks in their 30s from my age
like you're like this is wow he's the
rock at like
seeing like that like that just that
just disgusting like like remember
[ __ ] junior prom
you know
uh
in the club
like when you see that
when you see these heifers
doing that it it makes it less fun
for me
you know
i mean i don't know what to do but
that's you know it's a fact
i love raycon earbuds we all have them
they're less expensive than you know who
and you can use them they're great they
have six hours of play time great
battery life uh eight hours of play time
and a 32 hour battery life it's amazing
they're priced at around half the price
of other premium audio brands it's no
wonder raycon's everyday earbuds have
over 48 000 five-star reviews this is a
great company
people are losing their earbuds all the
time this is a great way to give them a
pair of raycon earbuds they'll never go
back
even if they haven't lost their earbuds
or damaged them they will and then
they'll fall back on raycons and then
they'll never switch have a couple of
raycons they're inexpensive get them buy
them for your entire family they're so
good they have awareness modes when you
need to listen to your surrounding if
you're jogging and it's not safe to be
completely uh you know tuned out you got
to plug in a little bit they have
awareness mode i mean it's really good
they have the perfect in-ear fit these
earbuds are so comfortable and they will
not budge trust me they don't budge
because you know with the earbuds they
fall out sometimes but not raycon i'm
really happy with this right now our
listeners tim dillon show listeners can
get 15 off their raycon order go to buy
raycon.com
tim do it if you like this show that's
buy raycon.com
tim to save 15
i mean it's too much they're giving you
too much
fifteen percent off on raycon's buy
raycon
dot com
best headphones you'll ever have the
moment we've been waiting for since
september is finally here in honor of
the big game draftking sports book an
official sports betting partner of super
bowl 56 is giving new customers 56 to
one odds on either team bet just five
dollars and get 280 in free bets if your
team wins draftking sportsbook is now
live in new york meaning you can bet
from almost a third of the country if
sportsbook isn't in your state yet play
draftkings daily fantasy football
contest for super bowl 56. new customers
can get a free shot at a 1 million top
prize with their first deposit
download the draftking sportsbook app
use the promo code tim dillon get 56 to
one odds on either team bet just five
dollars and get 280 and free bets if
your team wins that's promo code tim
dillon at draftkingsportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
super bowl 56 21 plus minimum age and
location requirements vary by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
sportsbook for full list of requirements
and state specific responsible gaming
resources voidware prohibited gambling
problem call 1-800 gambler in tennessee
or call or text the tn redline
1-800-889-9789
in connecticut call
1-888-789-7777 or visit
ccpg.org chat in new york call
1-877-8 hope new york or text hope new
york
six 467-369 if you were in new york
we'll leave you with this the great lori
lightfoot ties carjacking wave to remote
learning uh lightfoot watch we gotta
come up with a
a thing for light footwork like a
graphic and everything graphic
i mean
let's i want to i don't want to miss a i
don't want to miss a okay oh
a syllable out of this woman's mouth
because
it is rewarding to me on many levels
um
so whatever she said i don't even know
yet but the the teachers union has said
it is quote intellectually unsound and
politically venal for the mayor to make
such a connection so there's no one that
supports her
in the state for all of our chicago fans
the one the only the great lori
lightfoot
that we believe between remote learning
and
and the rise in carjacking look we
started seeing this rise in cases
in 2020 and i'll be frank and say
in chicago
there was a
correlation that we believe between
remote learning
and
um
and the rise in carjacking um having
talked to state attorneys who were
dealing with these cases in juvenile
court
and others a lot of parents went to work
during the day thinking their teenagers
were logged on for remote learning only
to find they're stealing cars and i
asked you know is there some new market
uh for stolen cars and unfortunately the
answer is
that for many of these kids who some of
whom had no prior involvement in the
criminal justice system this was um
pure boredom
but we're way past that point now
we've got to bend the curve on this
issue this is why we yeah well here's
what it is you know the kids
they're learning at home it's boring
you know
so they're going to steal the cars
they steal the cars
and
what are you gonna do they're bored
they're kids
i mean
so the teachers union's going insane
because she's essentially blaming them
she's going yeah well you guys are doing
remote learning and maybe if your
lessons were a little more uh compelling
the kids wouldn't be out stealing cars
how about not phoning it in when you're
on zoom
make it good
is this her quote here no this is from
the the public schools demanding apology
public schools demand an apology to go
every child in our public schools in
chicago deserves an apology from the
mayor who claimed zero evidence that
there was a correlation between remote
learning in 2020 and an increase in
carjackings which have been growing
across the nation so life is just
blaming children
yeah
to suggest that our students are somehow
disproportionately responsible for these
crimes is precisely the kind of
scapegoating and smear tactics black and
brown students and adults have had to
contend with in any discourse about
crime for uh generations
uh the great lori lightfoot lightfoot
watch again
we do appreciate you laurie
man when she finally
retires or is indicted or whatever
happens to her i will miss her
i mean you have no idea
wait a minute what is this
so she was uh some gang uh lightfoot's
tied to a shooting that happened in
austin texas as well that she had to
answer wait a minute hold the phone
are you telling me
that my two
favorite things
lori
lightfoot
corrupt mayor of chicago
and the violent hellscape known as
austin texas
are intersecting
how
has this happened i don't know
can you tell us yeah it's like because
you produce our show it's like a
crossover episode it's great so months
after publicly clashing over a deadly
shootout in austin mary laurie lightfoot
and cook county state's attorney kim
foxx appeared together thursday to
announce gun charges against a man who
was wounded in the gang-related exchange
of gunfire thomas dean 20 was charged
with aggravated unlawful use of a weapon
after he was found with three guns used
in the shooting fox said at least one
was a machine gun at the time of arrest
dean was facing three additional gun
charges in a separate case cook county
court record show so lightfoot then it
rained him in and then his reach
extended to uh to texas it seems
she's doing uh what she can here
go to drudge let's see if there's
anything breaking on ukraine before we
get out of here have we gone to war with
ukraine 48 hours to stop europe from war
130 000 russian troops
last ditch bid for peace
wow
what are you saying what's do you think
uh
do you think we're headed into or uh
russia's gonna invade the ukraine it
seems to just be sort of a u.s media
frenzy uh well i don't know if it's only
that there's something going on
i think we might be uh overstating it a
bit
well you know what it is no one's caring
about the olympics cove it's almost over
or is over
and nobody gives a [ __ ] about the
olympics so we need a war
we need something we need to keep moving
we need to keep going here
i mean and this is the way to do it
let's get russia involved
you know
we get a little news story out of it
i mean the media has been how many times
you gonna play the joe rogan compilation
no one cares
now you think vladimir putin's ever said
than the naughty word
i don't know
what if vladimir putin had a
spotify podcast
what if instead what if spotify comes
out and goes instead of invading the
ukraine
we're giving 500 million dollars to
vladimir putin
and we're signing an exclusive deal
and we're we're bringing on vladimir
putin
to do an exclusive podcast it would be
great
but now everybody is like wait a minute
what the [ __ ] is going on
but now we've reached this weird news
cycle where we we no one cares about
anything
and we're we're supposed to because
we've all been through two years of
caring
way too much
and now it's like i mean the super bowl
the ukraine
the carjackings
the kids with the guns the crime
it's too much
people are just disconnecting now from
anything
and they're doing a bad job of
convincing you that they care they don't
they can't we need a break
we need like a three-month break from
the news
like a 90-day sabbatical they should
just
stop the news for like 90 days
they should not have the news for 90
days
and let everybody just [ __ ] fill the
tank up again of curiosity no one even
cares
no one gives a [ __ ] let us get curious
again give us 90 days of reruns of stuff
let us
you know
wet our beak with some trashy reality tv
put on the real housewives let that guy
chase the woman around with the gun
let us entertain ourselves with that and
then three months later come and tell us
that ukraine got their ass handed to
them
but we can't handle it
you know we need a break let's go dark
for a minute
i was at that thing tonight you know no
one cares about anything
there's no feeling of
positive or even negative like it's just
so boring now
everyone you talk to it's just an
exercise
in
just
boring
meaningless
banalo
nonsense
nobody's got anything left to say
the facts [ __ ] so it's all over
right when comics still screaming about
that it's got no one's gonna care in six
months
then what are you gonna do
i mean like
these mandates have got to expire right
they've got to expire
people don't care anymore and i think
after a while they're just gonna these
mandates will get defeated they'll get
defeated in the courts
supreme court already struck a blow to
one of them
i i just don't think it's gonna be this
big
deal
for the rest of our lives i'm again
hoping
you know
what the [ __ ] do i know but
i'm just hoping
a bullish russian ambassador said his
leader mr putin doesn't give a [ __ ]
about the threat of western economic
sanctions because we're going to put
sanctions on them
and um
they'll be [ __ ] or maybe not here's
the thing with russia man they'll tell
their people
it's gonna be a lean winter
they'll tell them tighten it up
sanctions are coming tighten up
tighten up a little bit you know
it's not like america where everybody's
like living like way beyond like putin
will straight up tell the people and be
like hey
tighten it up
see how that one meal you got on the
table
make it into two
because we're about to [ __ ] up some [ __ ]
i don't know i go back and forth on it
every day with ukraine should they be
attacked or not
every time i'm in an uber i'm going no
and then i go yeah
i go no
then i go
yes
so i'm so divided what what are you what
where
what are your thoughts on this
uh well
the thing is if if they're not actually
going to war with the ukraine are we
inadvertently sort of tanking ukraine's
economy
because people won't do business with
them so if this is all like just for
clicks and they're really not going to
go to war then this is like
like we're the bad guys right
now
you're oversimplifying it
there's a gay
couple
they're both non-binary and they want to
perform they want to go to the olympics
and they're from russia
and they're being stopped from going to
the olympics
and wearing
the new non-binary gay flag with 15
different colors in it for every
conceivable thing anyone could ever be
they're being stopped of doing they're
they're being stopped by the government
of russia so we're going to have to go
into a nuclear war
for that so i don't know what you're
talking about about currency
manipulation and economies
you're losing sight of the [ __ ] prize
here
the prize is that everybody
lives happily ever after and peacefully
which is why we have to go to nuclear
war
it's why we need a nuclear war
it's quite simple
who is this woman this is some uh i
think ukrainian woman who's uh trying to
join the troops well i'll tell you right
now my money's on russia
take a look at her
she's 80 years old join civilians
weapons training with ukraine troops
um
i gotta be honest
i'm putting my money on russia
i have a lot of respect for this woman
and that's great
but if i was a betting man i'm not but
if i was
i'm gonna go with uh
russia
over this elderly woman
she looks like betty white
she's like betty white with a
kalishnikov
i don't know if that's gonna do it
that may not do it
betty white with a ak-47
i don't know
putin will vaporize her
but you know what she's doing there
um
and this is people don't even understand
this photo
russian troops
were yelling at trans people
and and misgendering them
this woman
is pointing a gun at the russian troops
as if to say
that will not be tolerated
we must go to nuclear war
i i don't see another way around it
if every country in the world does not
have the values that we do
we should go to nuclear war with them to
help the citizens of that country
it's pretty simple
if you were gay
and you were in russia and things aren't
great and i'm not saying they are
um even though in the big cities like
moscow and saint petersburg it's
probably better but let's say
you were a gay person you were living in
russia and you were dealing with
attitudes you didn't like some of those
attitudes for sure being propagated by
the government wouldn't you rather be
uh to wouldn't you rather sanction so
you didn't have food
or wouldn't you rather be nuked
that's a fair point
and i'm not four russians
shooting on gay people or whatever i
think that's um
you know it's horrible and i don't know
to the extent that they're i mean i i
think it's bad it's not good
um again ukraine's nationalists and this
is all false flag i mean this is i mean
that's what i'm thinking no this is all
what i'm thinking
i mean this is clearly like
sk is just russia doing this as a
justification for an invasion
worst case it's you know who
we are somehow involved in this
and we are send that's rambu right there
by the way
we are sending minecraft uh kids over
here
to uh
pretend to be ukrainian nationalists to
goad russia
into some type of military activity
because this doesn't seem real
but i could be wrong
there's like six of them by the way
there's six ukrainian nationalists
i mean you know
this is some type of op
you smell this right you can smell it
already they got the old woman with the
gun
she cares about a country so my i mean
you can
you can kind of feel
the narrative taking shape the ukrainian
nationalists are training
look at this old woman she cares so much
the elderly are going to come out with
weapons
the old people are coming out with their
guns
so i don't know who wants the war russia
us england everyone all of the above the
only people that probably don't are
[ __ ] ukraine these poor [ __ ]
they're not doing anything they're just
their economies being destroyed
and maybe putin does go in i don't know
i'm not making a [ __ ] prediction
i don't really know
you know
i'm i did i'm in the process of
purchasing a home i'm not going to tell
people where
but i'm going to say that um
we're going to have a another studio for
a few months
we're going to do so we're going to be
uh
temporarily relocated
from where we live now
beverly austin
we're adding another place
and we might have a little studio there
and this is not going to affect anyone
but it's on the east coast
so for july august we're going to be
maybe a little beaching
a little east coast
uh studio just for the months of july
august i don't know if the house will go
through or not
but
it will be
in a few months that might be a fun
thing
we love this studio it's a great studio
um
but we're gonna do a little i think a
little summer studio might be fun too
and uh we're going to uh
and what do you think that would look
like
uh so we got umbrellas for sure
and i don't know that's hacky
you're gonna go hack like that
that's what tony pizza was thinking i
know but we did this one's classy we got
big cactuses and
i mean i want to do something it would
be cool if we had a big animatronic like
shark what i want to do you calm down
what i want to do is get one of those
really those light those pictures that
light up you know
but we'll also do some episodes from
here but um
we got to also we all we can't ignore
the east coast we have to have a little
we had a great i did a great run of
podcasts out there and i just said you
we got to have a presence over there too
it really makes sense
um if nothing else but for to support
ukrainian nationalists
how great would it be next week lori
life was like the rise in carjacking is
directly tied to an uptick in violent
nationalism in the ukraine
there's violent nationalism in the
ukraine right now
and i stand with my brother vladimir
putin
at trying to get rid of the violent
terrorist threat of ukrainian
nationalists many of them are here in
chicago stealing our cars
it's quite disgusting
tim millercomedy.com we have some dates
um
this thursday i'm going to be in tampa
florida and then friday orlando sunday
san antonio
wednesday portland maine
thursday providence rhode island
saturday there's all these dates of
course albany new york concord new
hampshire toronto ontario finally
the 16th of march baltimore maryland
friday the 18th
the 19th philadelphia pennsylvania
nashville tennessee thursday march 24th
the 26th denver we have two shows we're
shooting a special our last shows on the
road for a while are glasgow
dublin
and london
and then
we're pretty much done
i'm doing this to may at the las vegas
mirage i'm gonna bomb i have no material
and then a casino in baton rouge who
cares
we're gonna put the hour out hopefully
in uh
april
and then we'll put it out we'll be done
and then we'll wait three or four more
months
i won't be screaming about nurses
anymore and whatever else i'm doing my
family in disney world and
if you guys have seen the set you've
seen it
um that'll be out and then we'll be uh
maybe doing some live podcasts every now
and then but concentrating a lot on the
show getting it out on time we still do
two episodes a week
one on patreon one here on youtube
always free
um
and we'll be uh you know consistently
doing that and we won't be on the road
it'll be a lot easier i know that it's
been frustrating for you
it's been frustrating for us
balancing uh everything going on the
road on the level we are and doing the
show but we've got uh the entire spring
and summer
of of that not happening so we'll be
focusing on really making this show
great whether it's uh from here
or from the new little uh studio on the
east coast you know perhaps
that could be
uh very interesting as always um
[Music]
you know we leave you with uh
our ticket link
timdylandcomedy.com
uh no merch people ask about merch it'll
come
it'll come
supply chain problems
we're figuring out how to do this the
best way
the nft will come relax we don't have it
right now
but it'll come
it'll come
don't worry your little head about it
don't drive through beverly hills drunk
or sober
with those [ __ ] psychopaths
you think they're gonna get us on the
way back
potentially how great would it be if
they got us on the way back
they're listening to the episode in the
car
they pull us over
every time you go to defend them
every time
you know
they just uh
react in in a crazy way
i felt like that guy was baiting me
trying to get me to say something
so that he could take me in for further
testing
this is exactly what i thought was
happening
right 100 yeah yeah about 10 times he's
circled back like you sure you don't
want to say it to my face though because
you can you're allowed to yeah that's
that's what they try to do
here's the reality folks if you're in a
situation with the cops
truly
if you're in a situation with cops
there's two options
you have to literally
just follow everything
that they tell you to do
or you have to kill them
good night